well we've been assessing the Windsor
framework now and since it was launched
I've already outlined some of the key
concerns that we have about these
proposals
um it was indicated by some in
government that they vote on Wednesday
was some sort of indecative vote of
support for the Windsor framework and
based on where we are at the moment and
the need for those key concerns to be
addressed we're not in a position to
endorse The Windsor framework and we've
made clear that we will continue to
engage with the government to have those
concerns that we have outlined properly
addressed
[Music]
support on the US so it doesn't matter
that you're voting against it well it is
important I think to indicate to the
government where we are at the moment
but that said we will continue to work
with the government we know that there
is further legislation that will be
required on these measures and we want
to see that legislation and we want to
ensure that what is proposed adequately
and property protects Northern Ireland's
place within the United Kingdom and our
ability to trade within the internal
Market of the United Kingdom as well of
course as trading with the EU
and with this all going on does this
mean that poor sharing is dead well we
are committed to storment
um but we've consistently said that what
we need is an outcome that unionists as
well as nationalists can support we need
to ensure that whatever arrangements are
put in place that they provide the
stability that storm needs on a
cross-community basis to operate
effectively
um I don't believe that what we have at
the moment is sufficient there has been
significant progress but there are key
areas of concern that remain and we hope
those can be addressed in the weeks
ahead
and do you expect the EU and the UK to
renegotiate
well I think it's important that the UK
government brings forward the
legislation that will be needed to take
forward any new arrangements and we will
want to see if that legislation
adequately protects Northern Ireland's
place within the United Kingdom we
produce some 77 billion pounds of goods
every year in Northern Ireland and 65
billion pounds of those goods are sold
within the United Kingdom so having
um clear and free access to our biggest
Market is fundamentally and vitally
important for Northern Ireland and we
need to get this right
and uh did you meet privately with Rishi
sunak when he was renegotiating the
Windsor framework yeah we have had a
number of meetings with the Prime
Minister I'm with his team in the recent
weeks to make clear to them our concerns
um uh about first of all the protocol
and now of course the Windsor framework
itself and we want to continue engaging
with the government to have those
concerns properly addressed and that is
necessary if we're going to make the
progress towards restoring the political
institutions in Northern Ireland I want
to see that happen and of course that
does require us to engage with the Prime
Minister and with the government